quella tutti ragazzi venuti a questo
nuovo video sono vigenti
oggi siamo stupido speciale ed speciale
va beh siamo su un video un bel video
come sono andato a los angeles per
cinque giorni ho fatto questo video
riassuntivo di tutto quello che è
successo più o meno in questi giorni a
niente ragazzi mi sono divertito un
casino e spero che il video possa essere
altrettanto divertente anche per voi e
quindi niente ragazzi partiamo layout
[Musica]
ok ragazzi siamo all'aeroporto di londra
a londra i cioè l'ultima volta che sono
stato qui ovviamente avevo trovato una
specie di cioccolata chiamata free gj
free gigena roba stranissima che ho
trovato la cioccolata mia la riggi j
dobbiamo andare a trovare altri gj a
distanza di sei mesi nello stesso
[ __ ] supermarket leger
ecco che si vedrà questo
perché i veri prodotti fa vj non muoiono
mai
ma chi cazzo è stato succo di merda
stiamo per partire siam incanalati
l'aereo è quello lì sarebbe un po più
grosso della macchina di mio papà
funziona niente io dormirò con questo
coso da donna perché ha regalato così
[Musica]
i ragazzi avete mai visto un ufo in vita
vostra cazzo
oddio fare le scale a e che ci accoglie
che diciamo calvari ok ragazzi siamo
arrivati in casa non posso farvi vedere
ancora con me perché è buio e rende male
ve la faccio vedere domani mattina
questa e camera mia devo inaugurarla a
modo mio quindi non siamo in francia
good morning intimi gira la testa
questi ragazzi venuti a questo nuovo
giorno in america
quello era una volta il mio letto sembra
che ci abbia dormito una mandria di
elefanti in calore però ci ho dormito io
mi faccia fare un attimino un tour per
farvi capire che cazzo è stata a parte
il fatto che fa c'era l'armadio che
ovviamente chiuso con la sedia perché mi
stavo pagando addosso prima di dormire
questi ragazzi sono case americane ci
sono tradimenti identiche a quelle di
paranormal activity di notte una cag a
questa un'altra camera ovviamente con la
culla e con l'armadio c'è ma vi rendete
conto porca [ __ ] di e può essere uno
che dorme la notte deve vedersi questo
con la culla a destra l'arma lla
sinistra all'armadio con lo specchio
dove si vedono i fantasmi comunque
questa è la e corridoio questo è nato è
enorme e staccare una cosa pazzesca
bella questa qua invece c'è una mandria
di mammut questa è un'altra stanzina
belli vino a guarda me lo piazzo proprio
davanti mentre dormo quello mi piace
proprio ok dopo il corridoio e mostra
ecco questa è la cucina e la cucina
naviga la nutella
ho trovato la russia non è mia e proprio
come degli horror che trovi la modella
in cucina a caso è una figata assurda
solo una roba non mi piace parte gli
armadi di notte roma chavisti ci ha
visti è un cazzo ma veramente ma vera
casomai spider man ditemi che riesco a
trovarlo in giro magari mi sbrana la
mano però canzone valsa la pena non mi
piace ninì in ogni caso fa attacca
dall'alto che bello non mi caga
affanculo
city
sì non lo so questa canzone ma allora ma
porterò la macchina a quel poliziotto
come se fossi veramente mi dai una mano
[Musica]
io
un gioco
sabato un che penso io
[Musica]
eboli
lei
[Musica]
si no
siamo agli universal studios di los
angeles coli mi stanno guardando male me
ne frega un cazzo è un parco a tema c'è
tipo mirabilandia cazzo ne so qual è la
buba gambe questa gente che mi sta
guardando male ma me ne sbatto altamente
le palle sapete che la starbucks
scrivono il nome sulle bibite eccetera
ecco io ho detto mi chiamo come ti
chiami lorenzo e mi ha scritto fi liri
che cazzo ha capito e leggermente figo
ma per taglienti e bassi muri ragazzi ci
vuole spiderman come giardiniere è la
cosa più benefico calende è assurdo
ma che dico e faccio anche voi vieni
vieni dovette e no così non sapere a
insetti nel self i ragazzi prima tappa
in assoluto montagne russe pietra di qua
la gamma siete se questa cosa può fare
no no no mai un anno fa volare 10 amore
di sé
ma no no dallo ragazzi vista parte non
si vedrà un cazzo di niente perché era
tutto completamente al buio però ho
messo i sottotitoli perché vale la pena
di vederla lo stesso lei
all
dispensa mettiamo a giurarsi quarti
ragazzi
tanto per cambiare vi faccio vedere
anche questo è bagnato quelli che dietro
quei ragazzi per che cosa ci sta
mettendo il kiwi ma perché se lo tolga
quanto
massimo
[Musica]
ma è vero che ancora di questo parco del
roccolo è schiantata sta benissimo
grandi promette bene so perché
[Musica]
morta
bello no
vabbè
no
ma chi non ce l'ha come una volta ma
vero è successo davvero è un figo della
madonna avere elezioni no vera piazza
nella piazza originale di ritorno al
futuro
guarda guarda
a
e vabbè
canzoni
verga
a cazzo
la madonna
[Musica]
fornello queste bellissime direttamente
bellissimo cazzo il mio preferito ma
veramente paga questa cosa dovete
fottutamente vedere ma questo elevate
redarca mai scoperti
detto questo stiamo per entrare a watch
world che quel film bello dove c'è
l'acqua ma avevo tante c proprio c'è più
di una bottiglia molto di più cinque
nomi e bagno l'utente
donna e l'ha dato arriva da li divide
non mi posso mettere 40 m nello zaino
mac e di ascolto perché si chiede ma sei
fuori dai maroni
o no
ma a questo
la gopro lì si scassa laico prati e per
concludere ragazzi il genio del viaggio
che l'ho incontrato mentre ero in giro a
caso completamente niente è una perla
che dovevo comunque mettere 15 st
siccome sono a casa libro no vabbè ma
sono tutti figli oggi ovvero le tv no io
no io ma sei bella tutti i ragazzi ed a
tutte le ragazze a me vedo bene vado a
tutte le carte macchia
era kanye west e ciò ragazzi questo era
il vino speciale cielo questo speciale
che cazzo ci centro lo speciale avrò il
cappello di lana che mi strizza al
cervello non sono comunque ragazzi
siccome ero in america ho approfittato
anche per fare una cosina quando sono
andato a santa monica c'era il segway
che sarebbe quello di happy meals ho
voluto fare un episodio di happy wyss
nella vita reale mettiamola così da far
uscire la settimana prossima ragazzi
primi se volete vedere video cliccate
qui e ma dalla sua stronzo ecco infatti
sono un genio faccio uscire domenica
prossima il posto di happy vis che mi
sembra la roba più [ __ ] della storia
quindi tenetevi pronti quindi ragazzi se
il video è piaciuto una solita lasciato
momento mi piace ai già voce di facebook
ea cavallo di video tra time descrizione
per anni mi piace a video vi regalo un
mini un tipo questo che era veramente ma
veramente figo
sono secoli cities tiratissimi diavolo
prossimo vino e le ragazze